you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is game 10
from the 2014 World Chess Championship
match between Magnus Carlsen and Vishy
Anand going into this game Carlson has a
5 points to 4 lead in this race to 6 and
a half points to determine a winner and
Anand with the white pieces in this one
he opens with d4 that still remains a
very close match anything can happen we
once again have d4 being played by Anand
when he has the white side and just like
we saw in Game one to turn the clocks
back a bit but we did see this already
in Game one that's how this match
started were once again revisiting in
this game 10 the grünfeld defense things
are different on this move four however
in game 1 what followed was C takes D
Knight takes and then Bishop d2 however
this time we have Knight f3 and on
Bishop g7 it's Queen b3 entering the
Russian variation of the Grunfeld
applying more pressure to the black
center black gives the center up and
will now look to strike at White's pawn
mass in the center the d4 and e4
structure how will black go about doing
just that how to get in c5 or a
five-night a6 is played seems a bit
awkward to deploy the knight on the edge
but it is facilitating this c5 advance
Bishop e2 c5 it is and on d5 the movie 6
is played doing something other than d5
such as D take C runs into Bishop to e6
development with tempo and then rook to
c8 the black pieces are now very active
White's still having to castle and get
their Bishop out this pawn keep in mind
is also not so easily defended Bishop
East III well notice that's not a
reliable square could be kicked around
with Knight to g4 this is not
necessarily the best direction for white
to go in instead it was d5 d6 castles he
takes de takes D and
this is where we stand very imbalance
position pawn structure wise at least
and very rich possibilities for
imbalances namely two minor pieces
versus the rook and pawn can show up on
board two bishops versus a knight and
Bishop minor piece and pawn versus a
rook very lively position anything can
happen in this game
this pawn needs to be kept under lock
and key can't necessarily block hate him
at his earliest point for as long as
this guy's around he could be sure
Knight b5 will be there to watch over d6
if black is trying to blockade
first things first however rook e8 it is
an open file a decision for white this
is the first think of the game what to
do with the bishop if anything at all
just yet rook d1 is an idea Bishop e3 f4
g5 maybe you could also consider
retaining the bishops options play a3
just to watch out for the b4 square it
seems a little bit slow but nevertheless
this move 12 many ideas here many moves
to go with he chooses Bishop g5
provoking h6 and only then returning to
e3 we'll see in a little bit that white
in fact makes use of that pawn advance
puts pressure on it Bishop f5 rook a d1
behind that passed pawn 94 a new move
that was available as soon as Bishop f5
is in could jump into that Square and
now we have whites Queen Knight and
blacks King Knight being exchanged this
Bishop is unmasked with this last move
Knight e4 decision point for black right
here how to recapture this is where some
time was spent about 10 minutes take
with the rook or the bishop in such an
open position this is really the first
one to be looking at gives the most
direction to the white side and typical
reaction is to do what exactly these
open dynamic positions you try to meet
punch with counter punch this is one way
to do it at some stage you're
threatening to grab on h6
not just yet because you have a loose
piece on e too but on rook takes e4
there is the counter-attacking queen c1
again this is not yet a threat because
of rook takes Bishop here but there is
ideas of maybe grabbing the knight or
even playing to first d3 and only then
taking here one interesting follow-up
could include Knight b4 and while this
pond has said if he's moving there's
even this cute move Knight c2 what is
that doing well on Queen takes Knight
there's rip take C rook takes Bishop
we're not going that direction but
nevertheless it should be a top
candidate choice in your own thought
process the one that gives the most
direction to your opponent especially in
these open positions we're having the
move at hand is very very important okay
well in the game it was Bishop takes
Knight pressure on the knight and pawn
d6 could be played here but instead it
was going to see one d6 would have been
interesting with Bishop to c6 is this
pawn a liability or an asset he might
get tracked down he might be more
accessible on this d6 square moves like
rookie six Bishop f8 and he can fall
white would have counter play maybe
against e5 and or h6 was an interesting
alternative we didn't have that instead
it was queen c1 and immediate punches
being thrown at age six it's also
clearing the way for maybe in some cases
you could grab the knight on a six and
then the pawn on c5 black follows with
simply developing ignoring the threat
here throwing a punch of his own attack
attack here is met with a counter-attack
against b2 and something other than
Queen to f6 if you're grabbing this pawn
here that is not a wise choice this
would be doing what exactly throwing
yourself into a pin that can follow
Bishop takes Knight Queen takes pawn
what are you doing about this Bishop
you're losing not a good choice in the
game it was Queen f6 h pawn is falling
and in return black gets the beep on and
with that the Queen's also are exchanged
one other idea at this stage here is to
not grab on b2 but rather g7 and on
Queen takes Queen rook takes King takes
bishop mass exchanges and after the
smoke clears both players agreed
afterward in the press conference
sharing some of their ideas they agreed
that this is really not much life in
this position after rook to d1 rook to
b8 looking for rook b5 this pond it's
tough to see how that guy gets rolling
just making a passing move if I don't
know if this h4 move is played there's
rook b5 rook takes rook pawn takes and
what exactly are you doing here on d6
you could take the knight and then this
pawn can be tracked down white maybe has
to be a little bit careful here this
pawn is certainly going to be scooped up
in short order we didn't have that we
didn't have this variation where white
captures on g7 but rather it's the
immediate Queen takes Queen the dark
square Bishop sin other words remain on
board and as a follow up Knight g5 now
if we take a look at the clocks right
here they're not accurate for this next
move this is where there was a big thing
on the black side clearly there's this
idea of having a knight for Bishop
exchange having that minor piece
imbalance on board after this next move
we see that it only registers about 2
minutes being spent but really this was
a half hour the clocks are just a little
bit off well a lot off but anyhow this
next move took about a half hour here on
Black's 19th move he ended up going with
Bishop to d4 now what exactly was being
considered here well for one if you're
playing Bishop to f5 in fact let me try
something else if you're avoiding this
Knight for Bishop exchange with let's
say the bishop to c2 in fact let me let
me show something other than Bishop to
c2 if Bishop takes pawn here that's no
good because of this and only then
recapturing one of the ideas you may
thought is to have Bishop takes pawn and
then if the bishops taken well you get
this guy in e2 but white would first
grab this Knight and only then grab the
bishop so grabbing the pawn is no good
is what I'm getting at playing here may
seem a bit appealing but notice how
after rook d2 what are you doing about
these guys if Knight b4 is played with
the idea of let's say hitting the rook
yet again there is the move d6 and on
Bishop c3 you can pick up that light
square bishop and look out what's
happening to f7 it's falling and black
is in a very bad position black is
losing this position the evaluation is
reading approximately 2.5 which is too
much can't go in that direction of
playing to c2 certainly can't grab on d5
in just a funny little note when I was
live-streaming this there was a relay
error and we have the move Bishop takes
g2 a move that many of you were
suggesting on Twitter and it was just a
relay err I'm just pointing this out
it's not a good choice because of Bishop
takes Knight Bishop takes rook and
Bishop takes Bishop anyhow just a fun
little fact there there was a relay
issue for some reason Bishop takes pawn
was played in the game it was Bishop to
d4 one other interesting line at this
stage instead of Bishop d4 is yet again
another Bishop move Bishop f5 I thought
we could see Bishop f5 however this is
another interesting option that white
would have as a follow up we could
arrive at this more simple dis ensuing
more simplified ending with black
playing Bishop g7 and then white
crashing through on f7 what do you do
about that on f6 there's d7 we could
enter this ending which I thought was
quite interesting and I wasn't quite
sure how exactly to assess this black
has a passed pawn white clearly has a
passed pawn just to step away I'm not
sure who stands the better side very
difficult endgame to assess
we didn't have that we didn't have the
Bishop move instead again a half hours
spent on this one Carlson decides on
Bishop d4 locking down the rook from
defending this d5 pawn now black is in a
position to grab him but of course white
snaps that Bishop off before he can rook
takes so this is where we stand now the
two bishops and a passed pawn minor
piece in balanced position pawn
structure a minor piece in balanced
position as well a pawn structure in
balanced position the rook drops back
he's seven it is this does run into d6
with the tempo we do have that rook d7
Bishop f4 you need to hang on to that
guy Knight B four hits the a to pawn and
during the livestream I was pointing out
well this is the this is really the
knee-jerk reaction to not want to you
know babysit the pawn with a piece but
instead just give them a kick but in the
game it was rook to d2 this is making
way for the rook to play to the B 1 or C
1 squares so it has its purposes as a
follow up rook to e8 rook see one rookie
six looking to track down that pawn soon
looking to interfere with the bishop
coordinating on the d6 square H for
flight square and at some stage there
can even be h5 to try and break down the
King side pawn structure Bishop e5 so
some smoke is now clearing with these
dark square Bishop being exchanged no
longer does white have the bishop pair
it's now a knight versus bishop
situation but as the as it follows up
here we have Bishop takes b7 and this is
now going right in for basically a drawn
position just like that this is clearing
up quite a bit where we end up in a rook
two rooks
well just a rook ending where there is
nothing really to play for after rooted
d2 it is at this point that the players
agree to a drop there's no life we went
from having a lot of life in the
position to this one petering out to
you know a dead drawn position the
computer evaluation is locked in at
zeroes not really a way to make progress
White has their base points covered
black could play rook to c7 keep his
base points covered what exactly is
there to coordinate on where is there a
great weakness not really seeing it
tough to even get this guy rolling no
good progress to be made in this
position and rightly so they players
agreed to a draw and with that this gets
pushed to five and a half points for
Carlsen and four and a half points for a
none and so with any game now we could
have a champion Carlsen is just one
point away he has the black pieces which
will be played on Sunday November 23rd
at 7:00 a.m. Eastern Standard Time be
sure to check that out in some way and
we'll see what happens at any moment we
can now have a world champion crowned so
I will see what takes shape
see if Carlsen is able to get a win if
it turns out to be a draw in game 11
well we're pushed to now game 12 and you
could be sure that that will be intense
now and we'll be going all-out we'll see
what happens soon enough so that's all
for this video as always I hope you got
something out of it take care bye
you